en escena cuantas cuadras tenemos aqui
qué número representa en este aspecto
bono tiene cuatro grupos y senac porque
tal vez hay cuatrocientos
cuatrocientos
Tengo tres grupos y así es como
puede entrar en 13 escenas más pero tres de
escenas y escribir más seis unidades pero
seis une 10
entonces puedes escribir esto como
puede escribir esto como 16 en lugar de
unidades para misiles unidades 3 en el
lugar de escenas para miss tres decenas
para mi tres decenas y maicon 4 no
lugar por las antenas para mi los cuatro
centenas que son 436 4 cinturones 36 436
vamos a salir estar ahí que tenemos el
esto tenemos esto el número es el número 3
503 ciento 12 312 y peso siendo
queríamos aquí ser 300 si somos
probando 306 unidades antes
estamos retirando de las unidades de
escribir esto vamos a deshacernos de la
unidades
estamos intentando una vez henan
estamos pagando un diez menos uno
diez y estamos pagando trescientos
estamos pagando estamos pagando 30 t
en los trescientos y que esta nuclear
eso
a ese bono tenemos cuatrocientos
estamos costando trescientos
para que tengamos ahí que tenemos un no
de los trescientos estamos caidos
con ciento uno sin tener derecho
podemos hacerlo aquí cientos más -
trescientos serán cien
ahora tenemos tres semanas y estamos
pagando un diez tan pronto como ganemos
esto terminaremos con 12 escenas pero de la
de escenas
3 - 1 2 de 3 - 1 en ex dos y último
tenemos seis
tenemos seis unidades estamos pagando el
unidades y en las que veremos con cuatro
6 unidades - las cuatro unidades anteriores
6 - de 64 y atacamos 436 menos 300 y
y 124 y verás como este proceso que
somos trescientos
una vez somos escena tenemos dos
unidades para obtener 124 que para ser
igual a cien de las decenas y cuatro
unidades